Well then, we'll get going. Thank you again to everyone for joining today's webinar.
Some quick introductions and a bit of housekeeping before we get into today's session. So my
name is Adam and this is my colleague Alex on my right. We're both enterprise advocates
at Volkswagen, working with our customers to help them get the most out of the enterprise
edition. My colleague Josh on my left is also on hand to help with the product demonstration
later in the session. In terms of housekeeping, this webinar is going to be recorded and uploaded
to our YouTube channel in the next couple of days. We'll also hope to follow up with an
email with a YouTube link over the next couple of days. Due to the volume of attendees on today's
call and our resource, so we can concentrate on the actual webinar itself. We won't be
doing a live Q&A during the session, but we would still want your questions. So please
use the Q&A option at the bottom of the Zoom window to submit any questions that you may
have. We'll then collect the questions and follow up with answers as soon as possible after the
event. Finally, at the end of the session, we'll make sure that you have an opportunity
to schedule a meeting with myself, Alex, and the wider team here at Portswigger to know more
about how Burkswigger Enterprise Edition can help your organisation's DAST needs.
So in terms of agenda, in the next 30 minutes, we'll aim to cover the following things. Our
thoughts on AppSec in 2024 and the challenges that we hear from our customers based on some
recent survey work that we carried out. We'll then look to cover how Portswigger addresses
those challenges as well as the launch of our new secure cloud platform for Burkswigger Enterprise
Edition. Alex and Josh will then bring this to life with a product demo before we round off the
webinar with an overview of our unique subscriptions and options to find out more about Enterprise
Edition, as well as some Q&A from a previous session that we've run that we thought might be useful for
today's audience. So in March, we surveyed our customers and it's been very powerful to hear directly
from experienced security professionals on their views to make sure that our thinking is aligned with
the rest of the industry. So what are the challenges that resonate most with our customers? We know that
human-led manual testing is still the key to securing web applications with 88% of respondents performing
manual security tests. However, manual testing is often not scalable with not enough resource to secure a
growing estate of web applications. Of the respondents that we had, only 44% have started to scale using automated DAST.
Next up, as development teams and application portfolios grow, security teams are still massively outnumbered,
with 50% of you saying that release cycles outpace your ability to secure apps.
As a result, this desire to release quickly often leads to vulnerable apps hitting production.
And finally, it's hard to prioritise your limited resource, 60% of the respondents reporting that they
don't have full visibility of their attack surface.
And this resonates with us. So Portswick has been on this journey for 20 years. We wrote the book that
educated a generation of pen testers, leading to the development of Burt Street Professional,
a tool created to make manual testing more fun, more efficient, and used to date by over 17,000
organisations in 160 countries. We've been part of this community for a long time, we see and feel the
pain of teams that are now accountable for securing large, complex web application portfolios. And with that,
our offerings and technology have evolved to address these challenges. We've worked hard to produce
consistent and quality driven solutions that are easy to adopt and powerful to use. Our years of
pioneering security research have also ensured that we're able to deliver an industry leading
DAST Scala that sits at the heart of Burt Street products.
So what common approaches do we see being taken? Security teams that we speak to are scaling in a range of
different ways, each with their own challenges and limitations. Many organisations start their
application security journey with manual testing. As we've mentioned, this is still one of the best
ways to carry out targeted security testing that provides meaningful results. However, we know this
time and resource intensive, sorry, we know that this is time and resource intensive, and certainly not scalable.
Securing pipelines is also key to finding vulnerabilities before they reach production. And the majority of
customers have started their journey with SAST and SCA tooling. And now DAST is becoming the last piece of
that puzzle. To support this, it's essential that developers are educated to become more security conscious
when developing their applications. And upskilling developers gaining adoption can prove challenging,
that is a key enabler when working towards DevSecOps. Many organisations also have active bug bounty programmes.
This enables security teams to harness the power and experience of a large community. While this is cost
effective, there is a dependency on external parties and can be resource intensive due to the variable
quality of reports. Finally, there are many types of automated security testing tools that you might already be
familiar with. You might have bolted on a DAST scanner via other vulnerability management platforms,
but you're likely unsatisfied with the performance, and often tell us that there's too much noise,
false positive rates are high, and you simply can't trust the results. Ultimately, you should have the best tool
for the job.
So to bring this story to life, let's look at a specific example from a AppSec team that I spoke to a couple of weeks ago.
So for context, this team currently uses Burksweep Professional, and it's a team of two. They work in a
large organisation that runs a global rewards programme, and they have 50 apps to maintain.
The majority of testing is split between their in-house resorts, and they also use external consultants
where needed. Yet they're still not able to work through all of their testing requirements.
The limited resource of the team also means that they don't want to manage any on-prem infrastructure,
and have a cloud-first approach to any new software.
So the challenge and impact of this being the 50 apps contain a huge amount of sensitive customer data,
and any breach would be obviously damaging to the organisation's reputation.
So the customer is now wanting to set themselves up for success.
So in order to achieve this, we've agreed on two primary objectives.
They have complete visibility of their attack surface, and know how vulnerable they are.
And they're going to do this with scheduled, automated DAST scanning using Burksweep Enterprise
Edition. This allows them to prioritise manual testing efforts with Burksweep Pro.
They also want to enable their developers to introduce DAST with CI-driven scans, something Josh is going to
demonstrate later. So they're securing their apps before they hit production.
This example was from a single call, but is likely to resonate with many of you here today, given that
according to our survey results, 85% of customers want to automate security testing in 2024.
With that in mind, I'm going to hand over to Alex to take a closer look at Enterprise Edition,
and how you can set yourself up for success. Thanks Adam. So just as a reminder guys,
so Burksweep Enterprise is Port Swigga's automated DAST solution. The idea here is that we're going to
have regular schedule scanning across the web application portfolio that you look after, giving us
that visibility. But also we can integrate that process into our development pipeline, so that we're
checking vulnerabilities earlier in the development lifecycle. And if we break that down a bit further,
we go to Enterprise as these team primary use cases. So for the automated scanning component,
again, we want those regular scheduled scans of whatever applications we look after in an automated
fashion. So it's very hands-off from that perspective, producing those results and giving us the visibility
into those vulnerabilities. And we can take that information, we can take those results and analyze
them in terms of either in the tool via the dashboards and detailed reports, we might want to integrate that
somewhere else, an existing management platform that you have or issue aggregation service.
And then secondary use case would be our integration into the CI CD pipeline. So for us, this solution is
agnostic, as Josh will cover in detail, so we can support any CI platform. We have the ability to fail
that pipeline build based on what the scan finds under user-defined thresholds. And we do provide
optimized scanning configurations from a DAST perspective in the pipeline. The notion that we're
not holding that build up for too long is quite often that we are in the time constraints when it comes to
releases. And that's more importantly, there's a very much a large educational piece around the
results that we're getting remediation by SOFR in terms of empowering developers. We've provided a
big focus on that as well. And we very much want you to interpret with those existing workflows, Jira,
GitLab, et cetera. So those are typically integrations that are bad.
Now historically, Berkshire Enterprise Edition has been available to customers in a self-hosted
fashion. So you deploy, manage and maintain yourselves. And now we have made that available
in our cloud platform. So hosted entirely on PortSquik's secure network, nothing for you to deploy,
host or manage, no maintenance for the team, and you get up and running and scanning within quite a
trillion minutes. A Bootsy Enterprise is built on the same Berkswick technology that you might already
know and trust. So in particular, if you're a Berkswick professional user today, and you're looking
to automate those data scanning needs, Berkswick Enterprise would indeed be the right solution for
you in particular. And in terms of that scanning, we do operate slightly differently to most in the
market. So we don't impose on restrictions in relation to things like number of applications or users.
And Adam's going to take us through some more detail on the subscription options and what those come
with as well. So now let's take a quick look at the tool itself. We're going to look at running and
scheduling scans, take a look at some common workflows, and Josh is going to take us into the
CICD component. So Berkshire Enterprise is a very straightforward concept. We use the concept of
sites. So sites are your target applications. And we want to ingest those sites into the tool. Each
side will have some form of configuration around it. That's in terms of scope, scan configuration,
authentication, all those good bits. And then around that, we want to wrap our scan schedule. And this
covers that automated DAST use case that we spoke about earlier. So the system just takes care of those
scans for us. And we can just spend time consuming and analyzing those results. Now, there are three main
ways to get our sites into the tool. I could very simply just create a new site. And that would take
me through a bit of a manual wizard to upload the information in order to create that site. Certainly
a good option for the POC or trial, whereas a new user just getting started, so you can get acquainted with
the type of information you can configure within a site. Then we have our bulk import feature. So you've
got lots of applications that you want to import on mass. We can complete the CSV template, upload that,
it will effectively populate outside tree forays. Or a third option, which is quite popular. So if you
want to be kind of more programmatic, look towards kind of scripting in terms of automating the tool.
Everything we see in the UI is also exposed by the GraphQL endpoint for the instance. So in terms of
creating sites, configurations, running scans, extracting data, that's all possible via GraphQL.
So what I've done is I've done a GraphQL query, put that into a Python script. Josh, my kind of
assistant, is going to run that for us now. That will interact with our instance. And if I refresh the page...
Josh, it's still going.
Josh, we'll give that a second to bring up.
That will then ingest those sites into the tool.
So that's quite a quick and easy way to get sites on board, but more importantly,
we can be very specific with the configuration around those sites as well with GraphQL in terms of what we want those sites to look like.
Josh, you can see here that's on boarded them into folders as well. And the folder concept is quite
important in enterprise because one, it makes life easier from a management perspective. So we might want
to segment our applications into teams, projects, staging, dev, whatever the case might be. That gives
a bit more control over organization. We can also do folder level configuration. So we don't need to
configure each individual site. We can apply that at the folder level and it propagates the sites within.
And then the role-based access control that governs our users can also be tied to the folder level.
So if we have a team, they're looking at for a folder in their applications, we can restrict that view so that
only they see their own data and nobody else's. Again, the government pilot role-based access control.
So one of the sites that I onboarded via GraphQL here, if I click on the details tab, we've got some
information that I onboarded, but not all, just to give you a flavor of what we can add here. So I've
got a scope, but no scan settings applied. So if I edit this site and scroll down, we can see here that
we've got a couple of choices for the scan configuration. So again, as a newer user to the tool, I would advise
you to look at the preset scan modes because these are nice and easy. You can just select what you like
the sound off relative to your use case and then all the settings are taken care for you.
But eventually you're probably going to want to explore the custom configurator. This gives you
complete control over the configuration that you're specifying. And the idea is that you build out a
library of scan configs or scan policies that you can apply either to sites or folders, depending on the
particular use case. And if you are a Burnt Suite Professional user, we can import those scan
configurations for a Burnt Suite Professional as well and apply those to Enterprise.
Now I could run a scan at that stage, but we're probably going to want to add some additional
details such as authentication. So I can do things like username and passwords. Recorded login sequences
is our mechanism for more complex flows like single sign-on redirects, multi-step or multi-page
logins. We've got PlatformWorth coming as well. I could configure an upstream proxy server to route the
traffic, the scan traffic through that proxy if required. Another use case might be custom headers
and cookies. So potentially adding more authentication or session-related elements to the scan.
Extensions are an interesting one. So again, if you're a Burnt Suite Professional user, you might be
familiar with both the Bat Store and custom extensions, and also more recently B-Checks. But just to
boil this down, guys, this is effectively custom scan checks. If we don't do a scan check in our default list,
that you're interested in, you have the potential to create your own and have a repo with a lot of
examples in as well that you can try out. And these would add those scan checks to your particular site.
Scanning pools. So with the concept of a cloud instance, we can add a scan from that instance.
So that means I want Portfolio to scan the site. And we can scan external sites nice and easy. And for
any internal applications that you have, you would have access to the IPs of the source scan traffic.
So you could do things like allow listing in your firewall. And so that we can scan from the hosted
instance to your target application. We can also configure that upstream proxy server to read the
traffic. That's another option. If for whatever reason we cannot reach the application from the cloud
instance, we do have the concept of a self-hosted scanning machine. So that is a resource that you can
download the installer from your instance, install that locally within your own environment. And the
scan can now run from that scan resource and report the results back to your instance. And we can segment
those into pools. So we might have different on-prem environments where we want these different
resources to sit. And we can tie the scans to those resources. And then finally, we can send scan reports
by email, build out our recipient list. And those recipients will receive a copy of the scan report
and complete. So that is the site configuration, guys. We can go ahead and save that. We'll go ahead
and run a scan. This is where we would schedule our site for scanning. So typically, we're going to pick a
start date and time. And on what basis we want to repeat that scan. So minutes, hours, days, weeks, or months.
And that can run forever, a set number of times, or until a particular date. We can just run one-off
ad hoc scans. That's right.
And then that would either run immediately in this case, or under the schedule, would run when the
schedule begins. And again, this will be taken care of for us in the background. If we do go back to a
site that I've already onboarded, I've run a scan, just to take a look at what those results are like.
This is a completed scan. Jump in here, pick the latest one.
So we have our start time, end time, how long the scan took. You can see from the graphs,
we start to build a picture over time of that security posture of the site. What's the security
trend, issues by severity? What kind of serious vulnerabilities are we uncovering? We can manage
these individually. So we've got our whole list, governed by the severity and a confidence rating
from the scanner. And we can filter on that basis as well. Those vulnerabilities that we care the most
about. When we select a vulnerability, we get all of our information. So this is our advisory. So here,
we've got external service interaction, our location, the detail for that vulnerability,
issue background, remediation steps and advice. There will always be a reference to our documentation,
web security academy, lab environments, again, a great educational resource, and the classifications
that we're done to as well. And of course, we need our evidence, so the request and the response
with the payload highlighted. And in this case, we've also interacted with the collaborator server,
so we have that request response as well. We might take this information and do some further
investigation in terms of, is this an exploitable vulnerability? And if we determine that it's not,
we can also mark it as a false positive. And this is then managed over time. So the next time a scan
runs, the system will know to flag this as a false positive against either that path or vulnerability,
depending on how we've managed it. So over time with the false positive management, we end up with very
clean results. And then we have specific scan configurations, if you have a particular interest
in doing things like reducing the concept of false positive.
So that's individual results, and then we could report more holistically,
and generate either a summary or detailed HTML report. We could then convert that into a PDF
in the browser, share with our team members, stakeholders. We have some compliance reports
around OWASP and PCI, and we're looking to build out this list as well. Or if we use something like
an issue aggregation service, another tool, where we want to collect this data, we can export that XML.
And again, everything is exposed by GraphQL as well, so we need to be more specific,
or integrate with another tool in a different way that will typically be handled by our GraphQL
from the shop today.
Quickly touch base on the team structure, guys. So again, we don't limit you as to how many team members
you're on board to the tool, all given by role-based access control. So we create a role,
then we create our users. Those users can sit within our groups and be governed by that particular set
of permissions. Within our groups, as you mentioned earlier, you can also restrict on a site or folder
basis. So if we don't want that group to be able to see our whole folder or site level structure,
we can do so. Now those will be managed within the tool itself, but if I jump into my integrations
page here, we can see that we do support SIN, SKIM, and SAML as well. So if you want to manage those
users elsewhere in your existing IDPs, you can do so. A quick touch point on issue tracking as well.
You can see here, we've got some integrations with JIRA, GitLab, and Trello. So if we want to
port those running realty issues and the advisory information that we covered, we can integrate with
these systems and track them in those tools. Very quick touch point on our scanning resources.
So this is essentially linking to our license, our subscription. We have scans that are running from
the Portswigger hosted instance. We have CI-driven scans, and then we have that concept of the self-hosted
scanning machines, which is our local op-ramp resource, should we need them. So we can deploy as
many scanning machines locally as we like. We can add them through the tool, download the installer,
generate a token with which to connect the scanning machine to your cloud instance,
and then you are free to configure those into your pools. You can know exactly where those scans are
running from relative to your sites. We'll jump back into our integrations page here, guys.
We're going to cover CI-driven scans now, so I'm going to hand over to Josh. I'm going to take a look at
that in shot too. Perfect. So I'll stop sharing my screen. Perfect. So what I have here is a really
simple GitLab repository, which just has a three different files in. So you can see that I've got
here a GitLab CI configuration file for actually defining what the pipeline does. I have a configuration
file which defines what the scan does, and I also have a recorded login JSON file.
Now our pipeline just says that we're going to pull down a Docker container, and then use Docker
1 to run it. So we're going to use Amazon's Docker registry to pull down our enterprise scan container.
We're going to bind some directories, and then we're going to tell the scan through environment
variables where the configuration file is, where to output the report file to, and then also the API
key and server URL using pipeline secrets, and we send through environment variables. Then we say at the
end that when the scan's completed, we're going to get our report file and publish it directly into
the pipeline. And what that then means is you can see the scan results directly through the pipeline
rather than having to draw through a console output. And I'll show you what that looks like in a second.
So if I just go back, and then I go into my scan configuration file, what I say in here is the
correlation ID and start URLs and some different things about the site. But basically what you can
specify in here is all the same as what you can specify through the enterprise console. And then
we also point to our recorded login JSON file down there. And then we also say that when we reach a
low severity or firm confidence issue, we want to fail the build. And that's quite a nice bit of
functionality that we've gotten there. Now we specify this configuration through the configuration file,
but you can also scan your size based on configuration, which you supply to environment
variables. And you can also give it far more config than I've given here. So if you just switch to
GitHub here, you can see all of the configuration that you can actually set. And it's quite substantial.
And this is on public-facing GitHub, which you can reach via our website. So feel free to go and look
at that in your own site and see all the different bits of configuration that you can set.
So if you just go back to GitHub and I go down to our pipelines,
I'm going to do now is I'm just going to run a new pipeline.
And hopefully just click on back down again.
It should just quickly kick off right now. So now if we go to our jobs,
and click through all the different options there, if you see here that the pipeline's been started,
we're going to pull down a container and then put down our scan container soon.
And as always happens with demo, it takes a lot longer. So I end up with nothing to say.
And we stay around for a bit. But what I'll do instead of sitting and doing nothing,
I'll go back to a scan which is already completed. And I'll just go to times.
And again, with time it takes me to get back here with me, so I'll just start for the scan to start.
But if we just go into here, and then we look at the job,
what you can see here is that as the scan progressed, you can see all the different statistics about what
happened. And you can see here that this is basically the same timeline view from the scan,
which Adam showed you, so which Alex showed you in the enterprise console before.
This is an unfortunate demo to show you, but just go back to one which actually
completed this job, and then go down to this one here.
That one also failed for different reasons. It does usually work, I swear.
But if we go down to this one, this is a good example. So you can see here at the end,
the issue is special breached, and we're going to exit with the failure code.
And then if we go back, and then we go to our year in here.
I'm just finding a place to find the test results.
We'll get there in the end, it just takes a lot of click on.
So then we'll click there, and then we go to the tests. We can see directly in here,
the would be able to see directly in here, the actual tests that are right.
And it will show you all the different things that you can see in the enterprise console.
What I'll just do now, you see the scan just been directly started from what I was just showing
before. And then you can see here the exact same thing that you would see for a normal scan,
whether it started through the pipeline or started through the enterprise console.
With regards to your site, you can see here that a site was created by a CI-driven scan.
Now, what you can notice is that because the pipeline was started directly through a Docker container,
that pipe, that scan is then run directly in that Docker container inside your pipeline.
And because of that, you can start, you can maybe start a site earlier on in your pipeline
and running on local hosts, and then scan that same site directly through the pipeline.
So that's something that you can do through the CI-driven scans, which you wouldn't be able to do
through a console-driven scan. But if we just go over to Azure DevOps, just to show how
platform agnostic it is. Because we're using that Docker container, we can do that in any
system that we want to. So you can see here that I'm using Docker one here, and it's all,
it's exactly the same command. And the only thing that's changed is the syntax for those different
commands. And what I was showing here, which I couldn't show in GitHub, so the artifacts that
expires. Let's go down to our pipelines. And then if I click into here, and let's go to this
key here, and we stick off it, you should go to our tests. This is what I was going to show you before.
If I just collapse this section here, you can see all the different things that we stand for within the
pipeline. You should click into here, you can see the stat trace, which contains the severity,
confidence, patch, issue detail, and all the same config that you could absorb, all the same information
that you could see directly through the Enterprise console. So again, that just really stresses that
anything that you can do through the Enterprise console, you can also do through the console
through the pipeline. And also you can run the same thing in GitHub and make things a bit easier
for you, because we have this custom CI-driven scan at GitHub version, because that's something
that you're using. But yeah, that just shows how you can do a CI-driven scan in more of a
convoluted way than I would have liked to, but hopefully you have got the same plastic
process that normally would do. So I'll just hand it back over to the guys now.
Cheers, Josh. Thank you very much. And thank you, Alex, for the demo. So to recap,
we're obviously very excited that Berksuite Enterprise Edition is now available in the cloud. As we've
mentioned, this enables you to run automated DAST using the Berks technology that your teams are likely
already using and most importantly, trust. And as we've demonstrated, we can run both scheduled
automated scans from the UI, as well as integrating scans within your CI pipeline.
It's also probably worth covering off at this point, for those of you who are not aware, we have
multiple subscription options available with Berksuite Enterprise Edition, depending on your
organisation's scanning requirements. So all of our subscription options include unlimited users and
unlimited applications. As a reminder, we don't charge based on any application or FQDN limit. But
just to touch on those subscriptions a little bit more. So Pays Your Scan, this is a flexible,
usage-based DAST scanning solution. So you can run intermittent scans on your applications and you
only pay for the scan hours that you actually use. This often, we find, allows you to develop an
understanding of your organisation's ongoing scanning requirements before moving to one of the other
subscriptions. It's very straightforward subscription options of purchase, you can go directly to the site,
it's linked to a saved credit card and we charge monthly in arrears for that model.
We then have our classic subscription. So this allows DAST scanning across an unlimited number of
applications, but with a fixed number of concurrent scans. And myself and Alex and the wider team can
advise on how many concurrent scans is going to be applicable based on your specific use case.
And then finally, we've got our unlimited subscription, which has been incredibly popular. So this has no
application limits, no user limits, and crucially, no limits on the number of scans that you run.
This is available for both self-hosted and cloud, as all the other subscriptions are as well.
And unlimited specifically is perfect for organisations with a large web application portfolio,
heavy scanning requirements in both scheduled scans and CI-driven scans, often supporting multiple
teams in your organisation, hundreds, if not thousands of developers.
So what happens next? So obviously, we want to talk to you about DAST scanning, and we'd love to
arrange a call to better understand your challenges in your organisation and how BERT can hopefully help.
So there should be an email in your inbox shortly that contains a meeting booking link. After we fully
understand your requirements, we can then run a tailored demo with you and your wider teams to ensure
that any evaluation or POC is a success. So please check your inbox and book a call using that link.
If you can't find a time that suits, please respond to the email and we will do our best to accommodate.
As I mentioned, right at the top of the session, as this is a second in the series of webinars that
we've run. We took some of the Q&A from the first session and Alex is going to cover some of the
frequently asked questions. We do have a full doc and we will be happy to email that out after the call.
I just thought it might be useful to cover some of the more popular questions during this session.
Okay, guys. So with the cloud version, is it possible to scan internet applications that don't have
internet access? As you mentioned, the self-hosted scanning machine concept, that would cover this
scenario. So we can deploy that self-hosted scanning machine into the network environment where our
application lives. And then that self-hosted scanning machine requires a single outbound connection to
the cloud and seems to record those results. And as you mentioned, we can manage those with the
pools concept. So we can make sure the scan is being started for the right resource.
So is Virtual Enterprise Edition in the cloud replacing the self-hosted version? So that is a no.
Virtual Enterprise Edition in the cloud. We will continue to offer the self-hosted version,
should that be suitable for your use case. And we have no plans to support for self-hosted.
Does Virtual Enterprise Cloud Edition have any manual testing tools like Repeater or Intruder? So as
I said, no. Virtual Enterprise is an automated DAS solution. So if you do have a manual testing use case,
that would fall under the use of Virtual Enterprise Edition.
And where will my organisation's data be stored when using Virtual Enterprise Edition?
So it is stored in Portswinger's secure cloud. In terms of the physical location, that would be the
Republic of Ireland. And we do have a cloud FAQ document, which goes into more detail on how we
store and secure data in the cloud instance, which we would be happy to share. And we do have Portswinger's
Trust Centre, which has a lot of our security style questions and answers.
Portswinger's